go ahead
thanks jen couple questions um to follow
up on the border why has this
administration been so reluctant to call
it a crisis with a huge
uptick in the number of migrants being
detained including thousands of children
if that doesn't qualify as a crisis what
does well because we think that it's
most important to explain the
substantive policy of what's happening
uh what the root causes are of why these
kids are coming
and why what we're doing to try to solve
what is
a very challenging circumstance
go ahead thanks jen a couple questions
um to follow up on the border
why has this administration been so
reluctant to call it a crisis with a
huge
uptick in the number of migrants being
detained including thousands of children
if that doesn't qualify as a crisis what
does well because we think that it's
most important to explain the
substantive policy of what's happening
uh what the root causes are of why these
kids are coming
and why what we're doing to try to solve
what is
a very challenging circumstance
[Music]
okay
all right here we go ladies and
gentlemen we are live i'm
i am i am all over the place right now
welcome to the show
uh wayne dupri leah bella and brian
smith
i am trying to um share some of this
stuff at the same time
uh sorry to play that video a couple
times
i thought it was a little bit longer
than that but um brian
the uh the administration
is having a hard time in justifying all
those kids
uh at the border we were talking about
it yesterday
it was we're going to surpass all of
2018 in the first quarter of this year
yeah i think we already did there you go
they said they said at the end of
january
uh it was expected 20 000 they were
seeing 77
000 it's and she's she's up there
complaining she's like
well we're trying to understand what's
going what no no no
you're gaslighting people you know
exactly what happened
you all summons them you called them up
they have dual body shirts on
you guys told them to come don't play me
like
that and don't you think it's quite
suspicious that you know texas opens
back up you know they're going to blame
if chronovirus
go back up they're going to blame abbott
when essentially it's probably all the
illegal immigrants running over here
just completely packed full with the
disease with the virus
greyhound bosses like you're not getting
on here unless you can get a kova test
right and all these policies and all
these ideologies that they're putting
into place
from san francisco to new york city i'm
i was reading the article earlier this
morning and it just refreshed my memory
and it blew my mind that i totally
forgot about the weather
underground movement uh dorne
uh uh the the solanski and all of them
uh they're in office now
they're in academia now they're the ones
running the country now from the 60s
fast forward now that's why you got the
chaos that we have today because that's
what they want
they inherently they want crazy chaos
and then claim to fix it and we'll fix
the chaos well it was easy during joe's
campaign to talk all they wanted and say
what they could do and what they will do
but it's really hard when you start
proving that you're not doing all those
things or you're doing them and then the
repercussions come in so at some point
there'll be egg on his face with these
bad decisions
and we're starting to see that but don't
cover well
i don't know you think they're covering
cuomo well or not
well i mean his book deal just shut down
a sixth woman came out
six yeah normally when they're six
there's a hundred so i'm sure there's a
lot more than that it's like deeper
yeah so uh yeah i think that you i think
that uh
como is just slowly trying to get out of
this with a little bit of class
but i think he's done and just a matter
of time until we see that
well leo torres said that um he
he will survive it but he's political
poison
yeah i agree i agree no one's gonna want
to touch him
well just like hillary clinton she is
political poison
and i think i i don't see her coming
back into politics although it was
floated
but she's so wretchedly awful i don't
think they'll bring her back either but
she survived
yeah i mean everything she touched yeah
turned to absolute
crap so i would assume it's going to be
the same with him
let me tell you um this show is being
brought to you by birch gold
merch gold dot com forward slash
wayne like we were saying or like we
have been trying to let you know
uh the congress is
congress is out there right now um
they are voting today on h.r
one okay i think
so with the with the money and all that
stuff and everything
well yeah
the money is has to do with h.r one t
right
they're both the same thing well if
anything the democrats vote on always
ends up uprooting our stock market and
turning it sideways so
yeah everything let's do their money
yeah um right now they're voting on it
it's going to pass the house
so it's going to go to biden's desk
so much money uh they i don't know where
are they getting it
i don't know where to get in the trees
because california burned down but i
i mean i i don't know where to get all
the all the trees to make this money
but one constant is the elementals which
is
gold by gold and at birchgold.com
they will send you a free information
kit decide to do a sign up
and then you will get some more
information about
how to invest and then you can
do something for your kids that
congress keeps telling you that they're
doing but you can do it yourself
well it's zero cost to request the kit
so remember that there's no no
obligations and it's zero cost
and um they actually specialize in gold
iras so you can convert a portion of
your ira or your 401k
into an ira back to fit by physical
precious gold
so fight for your financial future go to
birchgold.com
wayne yeah hr one bill is the voting
rights bill
that's the one that we've been
complaining about that that
makes permanent the complete and utter
nonsense that happened
this past year uh so if this passes
you're going to have more nonsense so
secure that 401k that you've made so
much money in in the last couple of
years
you got to lock in those those those
earnings
of your hard money don't be like some of
the guys that i knew
back in in uh uh 2013 2012 2013 2014
when they couldn't retire because their
401k was
it wasn't worth anything now it's worth
something
you gotta protect it we are
we are broadcasting on facebook rt
um you'd well uh
we're not broadcasting on youtube but r2
rt's youtube um
periscope but that's going away so if
you're on periscope you need to get over
to rumble
i think you got two weeks left on a
periscope maybe maybe a
plus or minus a few days you all got a
couple weeks left yeah just march 31st
that's the drop dead date for them
live be live we are also out out there
for d
live but we're asking everybody to go
over to rumble it doesn't
take it look y'all it really doesn't
take a lot
to go over to rumble rumble.com forward
slash
wayne dupree show as a matter of fact um
as a matter of fact i'm going to show
you something real quick
gonna help out everybody
uh you can go to rumble.com this is
the the web this is the web
interface right here you see that
rumble.com
that's what you see right now right it
now
over to the left
let me make this a little bit bigger see
that
there's a live right there you meet to
the right top right screen if you're
looking at your monitor yeah top right
you see that top right right there
there's a live right there you see that
wayne
live right there if you click on that
that takes you right here and then
oh that's easy that's much easier than
how i do it you gotta you don't pay
attention how to do that because that's
a lot easier than what i was doing
okay just that easy
so we look we we want you look we we
left youtube
actually we left youtube a while ago and
then we decided
that for cpac we will go back to youtube
just for that weekend but we haven't
gone back we haven't gone back
uh rumble is our home so that's where we
want you
to go to watch the show and also comment
in the comment section now
um we we're going to have a couple
guests a little bit later on
today but some of the news is going on
about right now uh you already know that
the dems
are voting today on biden's one trillion
dollar covet package
most of that has nothing to do with
covet as most of y'all know
um some of them call it stimulus package
the only thing getting stimulated
not to be vulgar but to stimulate it is
san francico
new york city and all the failed
democrat cities right
and you know they keep saying that um
this is the biggest progressive package
of all time um
probably it's look it looks like it's
gonna be bigger than
what lg lbj put out there so this
so now biden has his name in the history
books
as the new lg lbj i guess
with all this but
lbj put out programs
to create the issues that we have today
and he was aware that he was putting out
those programs joe's doesn't even
realize what's going on today
right joe's not putting out programs he
he's just spending money
so you know when when they say in that
uh you know that this is this is the
biggest progressive
uh uh oh and and then yesterday
before we left we were like yeah um
there was a strategist that got on
the news yesterday and said that this
package the 1.9 trillion dollar package
is going to lift 50 percent of children
out of poverty
that's a bunch of horrendous
and if it does lift up 50 what about the
other i mean you brought that up what
about the other 50 who picks and
uses and right and you know what and i
tell you this i tell you this point
blank
if it does i'm switching parties well
not only that but if it does
i will beg i will beg to do it again to
get
the other 50 out sure but here's the
question
so is the money just delegated for
specific things to lift them out of
poverty or does the parent get it and
then spend it on a big screen tv
because if you get it and spend it on
big screen tv how is that lifting the
child out of poverty
the child is to the side so in turn i
feel like that is a straight up lie
how can you say they're getting out of
poverty if the parent if it goes into
the parents hands they could be doing
heroin
they could just be randomly buying a new
ipad for themselves buying their new
boyfriend something
i don't understand how you can make that
statement and really not know where the
money is going
but isn't that what they do with
everything they make the statement and
not know where the money's going
don't even care don't care about uh just
like with the teachers that you don't
have to show that you did something good
you just have to be there y'all know me
i ain't gonna lie to you
if it lifts 15 of the kids on the
property
i'm switching parties i'll be with you
i'll join you hand in hand here we go
here we go we got two
we got oh we got three no we're not
saying
we're going to switch parties together
and hold hands like hands across america
kumbaya
three potential potential democrats
three potential
i'm waiting wide open because
we're saying that because it's a lie
it's a it's not gonna lift anybody out
of poverty
it's not because it's not even going
toward
inner city poverty issues
it's going toward the kennedy center
there's no poverty in the country what
was it what was that like a hundred
million again
like the kennedy center in these last
three packages so
in 365 days we've got one year we've got
three packages now
the kennedy center's got more money in
this past year
don't think we've ever given them
internal
or not independent audit more like okay
you guys even know what goes on at the
kennedy center like have you ever been
there like what goes on there
i don't know yeah like no one even
really knows what it is
i do witchcraft yeah i was gonna say
that when the skull and bones go to hang
out yeah follow the tunnels the
underground tunnels huh
ladies and gentlemen we have a we have a
guest coming on uh
madame at cpac uh actually i don't even
think we got a chance to interview mr
pack but i told him that
uh we would get him on the show so
that's one thing that i wanted to make
you know i take care of my promises
this young man is running against
uh maxine waters out there in california
i i've seen some of what he's doing in
the community
and he is out there on the ground
uh working hard and he
says he has a chance to meet maxine
waters
let me show you a campaign clip and on
the other side we're going to have
mr joe collins
i am a bonafide registered proud black
republican
america is tired of maxine waters and
her
radical leftists that's why black
conservative
navy veteran joe collins is running for
congress
joe isn't running because it's trendy or
the cool thing to do
joe is running because he loves his
country and community
can you help joe collins out today by
contributing 2020 to his campaign
this will send a clear message to maxine
that 2020 is her last year in office
together we will defeat maxine waters
put a real patriot in congress instead
thank you god bless your family and god
bless america
i'm joe collins and i approve this
message
all right with that said mr joe oh wait
hold on i thought i had missed you
guys
good morning good morning
that was an incredible incredible ad
there man great great job
absolutely thank you thank you we have
one team that put that stuff together
for us
yeah yeah i mean um and and actually
actually on your website there's a whole
lot more
videos that uh people should um get used
to
on your website but you are running
against maxine waters
uh and uh that
in years of ineffective
uh policies to fix that community
why are you doing this let let the
audience know
why you are doing this what is
motivating you to do this
and do you really feel like you have a
chance to win
well the motivation to run is is
absolutely simple i'm from south central
los angeles born raised
um you know had to move to texas when i
was in high school because our house was
shot up in a drive-by
i joined the military in 2003 got out of
the military in 2017 to get involved in
politics
and so south delay is my home and you
know maxine's been representing it for
over 47 years i'm 35 years old and when
i was growing up it was called the hood
now why is it you know 35 years later
still called the hood where's our
progress was our
quality jobs are quality education we
have none and that's direct
representation of the leadership that's
been there
um as far as do we have a chance to win
it absolutely we should have won the
last election but we didn't pick up the
ballots by the house illegal here in
california and you know assuming that
everybody plays by the same rules
was uh was my fault
now i can attest to that i lived out
there in
south la i had a shop actually in
southgate south central l.a and
there's a reason why linwood is called
lynn hood still to this day
i mean you had to watch riots watts
never recovered from the riots you
drive through watts and you'll see why
but so so you're
you're going to show exactly how
ineffective
uh maxine at the age of 82 gonna be 83
this august
damn well i don't think i have to show
how ineffective she is you can you can
write down a dish you and see for
yourself i think what we need to do is
show the people that
you know i care about the community
regardless of if i'm a republican or
democrat i think that's the biggest
issue
and um you know roll out the plans to
improve the community education bring
quality jobs back getting trades
uh back into school things actually
matter lowering the cost of living so
people can be able to
live above the poverty line okay so i
saw one of your campaign videos and in
there you said
i survived maxine's district and i
thought that that was a powerful
statement
um and then it goes on to say about how
homelessness is up 53
gang activity 43 are living below the
poverty line
and then the major blow it's a 264
percent higher rates of homelessness
under maxine's belt i don't understand
how
anyone would vote for her at this point
so i'm obviously you're in touch with
the community for those that are still
on the fence which i find
absolutely insanity what are you doing
to get them across
to you we're we're taking care of the
community i mean during our last
uh campaign for 2020 we giving away over
10 000 pounds of food we give away
over 15 000 pounds of school supplies 25
000 backpacks we've had on the spot
hiring fares
we were absolutely visible in the
community i'm i'm not untouchable you
can come to one of my offices
in the district and call me and i'll be
right there if i'm if i'm
in uh if i'm in california um staying
actively engaged and showing that you
know somebody actually
does care for you i will talk to you can
make plans to rebuild or get some
government funding back to
whatever organizations needed
you know uh when you hear the word uh
republican
especially these days uh
it's a it's a huge turn off and
many minorities uh within that community
are probably politically homeless
and they and look at some of the
republican leaders
they probably don't think that they
relate to him which is why they haven't
signed on to the republican party
what do you talk about when you go into
those areas and uh
to to have them say okay i can trust
joe uh i think what
i talk about what makes me different
from everybody else is i keep it real
um being from south central l.a i
understand the things that i grew up
with on a regular basis it was hard for
me to push narrative
in the community that that community
doesn't understand like i'll give you an
example this is an example that i use
all the time
um in our community we say that uh well
a lot of people say that
you know black latinos are shot by cops
and if you tell a regular republican
that or a conservative they'll say well
black people kill black people
more than the cops kill black people and
i think that both of them are a problem
i don't think that one should be negated
just because someone else has statistics
as this i said if cops kill black people
and we got to figure out to
a way to bridge the gap between a law
enforcement and a community
but if black people are going to black
people then we got to figure out a way
to stop that
and deliver better influence to our
communities and so um
that's the difference between me and
everybody else i keep it real i'm not
i'm not gonna deny the issues that we
have in the black community i'm not
gonna say that all cops are good but i'm
not gonna say the all cops are back i'm
not gonna
say that black people are not killing
people more than everybody else but i
will say that there
is an opportunity for us to create a
better uh community that everybody can
live beneficially
and uh have a great quality of life
now so with the hr one bill that is
probably going to pass how concerned are
you with the mail in voting because
what i don't want to see again is
everybody say oh it was the melon voting
again like we have to be proactive about
this now
we have to combat that because it's
coming
i think with hr one just like with any
bill the bill is a problem the lack of
uh leadership and lack of action is the
problem so we complain about mel and
valenzuela one to the fact of the matter
is we never have republicans going into
the inner cities
to engage with people regardless if they
like us or not so the melon balance
wasn't the problem it was a lack of
action from the people who were
legacy leaders in the republican party
you know we were in the communities we
didn't collect ballots but we complained
about the people who did collect ballots
so i think that
you know before we want to complain
about something we need to look at
ourselves and find out what type of
action can we take i mean going on
social media and talking
um to our conservative our republican
bases is all great but that's not going
to win you any elections
when you look back in history do you
remember the gulf war
when it began and you remember when
pan-american airlines filed for
bankruptcy
maxine was in office
that's how long she's been around and i
know you bring up
the republican party and we talk about
this on the show all the time
and i know wayne has helped me to get my
mind right
when it comes to the republican party
and i complain about chicago all the
time
and i complain about our big city here
in cincinnati all the time
there is zero republican outreach
i know the republican party and the
leaders they will
not invest money in something that
doesn't
they can't see fruition um if you're a
candidate
they will not even look at you unless
you're raising a quarter million dollars
uh we got to hijack the party but i mean
what do we do i guess that's what i'm
saying my answer i don't know what to do
i i think that you know and i hate to
say this like a lot of
republicans have to have liberal
mindsets they expect
the party to help you with whatever you
want to uh but then they turn around
and talk trash about people who are the
government to help them in their own
lives
one thing that we've been very effective
at doing our campaign is
creating a machine to where we don't
need the party i will partner with the
party to get certain things done
um but it's strictly a partnership we
don't need the party to
uh help us in our elections we don't
need a party to outreach we have to stop
expecting a party to do something we
have to be able to create our own
machines
within our own organization so we can do
our own outreach the party is not
perfect at raising money
the party is not perfect community
engagement party is not perfect at
picking candidates
that's that's our job that's something
that we have to do on a regular basis
and so
until we lose that mindset of we need
the party to help us then we're always
going to be
in a liberal mind they thinking that
somebody is supposed to help us do
something and when they don't we get
upset about it
let me um we play we played a video
yesterday and i want to play the first
part of it to you
and because you're out there in
california i don't know
if you know about this we just found out
about it on sunday
but i want to get your take welcome back
to the
big sunday show san francisco taxpayers
are footing
a 16.1 million dollar bill to shelter
homeless people in tents
they're calling them villages the tents
come with a whopping price tag of
61 000 a piece per year
they even come equipped with bathrooms
and food service
and 24-hour security the annual cost of
one spot
is one in one of the sites is two and a
half times
the median rent for a one-bedroom
apartment in san francisco wow
leo joe
61 000 for a tent
what the hell is going on out there man
that's what we got to deal with on a
regular basis and that's like one of the
dumbest things i've heard in my entire
life because
it's like one thing that people have
failed to consider right now is that the
cost of living in california is
extremely high
you know and it's not that people can
afford to live not that they won't have
money
they can't afford to to get housing the
cost of living goes up significantly i
mean we can look at the gas prices the
housing prices
they're trying to cram everybody in
between the 405 and 110 freeway in the
beach and
it's like you know that's not a
sustainable plan and all of these things
are temporary solutions let's give some
tents to homeless people okay so what
about lowering the cost of living so
they can
have you know their own place to live
how about bringing quality jobs like how
about
some restrictions on on development and
building in
in california that'll lower the cost of
living but you know nobody ever thinks
about that they come with the bright
idea oh well let's
put more tents on the streets and make
streets more dangerous because these
people are getting
i mean like we just left san francisco
and sacramento and literally there's
needles all over the streets
so people have the little the little
pots of their their junk and they can
shoot up and you know people come bring
them food and they keep it moving
but no jobs no no lowering the cost of
living
no finding out how we can reboost the
california economy and
and we have people that think that
government is doing an outstanding job
so for those who want to go ahead i was
gonna say no personal responsibility no
moral guard rails
there's nothing it's it's it's do what
you will when you will how you will
whatever you will uh back to south
central again or south of
l.a i mean there's whole sections of
rvs and campers and trailers and
industrial areas where
where you've got dozens and dozens of
people sleeping in a a five-man
rv you know that's 30 40 years old just
sitting there on the side of the street
and then they walk pro street go to work
whether they're legal or not who knows
but
but this is acceptable i guess and and
that's
that was always my problem and i think
that was the biggest reason why we
left l.a is because paying rent at
fifteen hundred dollars a month
yeah ain't never gonna get a house yeah
that's true
good i was just going to ask people want
to donate to you or follow you where can
they find you
what's your website my website is joe
collins for congress.com you can find me
on all social media platforms at joey
collins
great you got those joe collins shoes on
i love those shoes
i do i love this one yeah they'll be
awesome you gotta get a chance watch
this camping video with the shoes on
because those are cool
all right joe um hey look thank you i
i know it's early and i know that you
are probably getting ready to do some
community work
out there but uh uh
connect with us again so that we can
bring back on
maybe even uh get a video out
with you on the street and uh
talking to the people out on the street
because that because that's something
that we don't see
a lot and yeah especially when it comes
to candidates
uh but uh you know good luck against
maxine waters
hopefully you can get her on stage for a
debate hopefully she ain't gonna do that
that's like that's like trying to get
joe biden to talk to the press we know
that's not good
well you know what i got it i got a tip
for you take take your debate stage to
her house
we meet her mansion yeah just which one
that stick isn't that sick wow
all right man thank you a lot thank you
thank you thank you i'll talk to you
okay joe joe is uh again joe collins
congressional candidate from california
u.s navy veteran and
joe collins4congress.com that
is his connect joe collins
for congress for glad to see him getting
out there
in the district and actually talking to
the people
um real quick we gotta
we got another um guest coming up for
you just a few seconds
but if you are watching on rumble make
sure you are sharing it
on rumble if you watch it on facebook i
put
the rumble link on my on my
public page and my private page
if you're watching on facebook
share the rumble link okay uh
again we have given up on youtube we
didn't get kicked off we didn't banned
we just left uh they they pretty much
gave up on us
you'd make a searchable uh you know
subscribers and notifications and then
when you're supposed to get paid the
money that that is due
you whatever yeah and
i look at i look at um youtube like i
look at the congress people
the american people gives you money
and youtube takes half of it
or nearly half of it the donations and
then they gaslight you
and make you feel guilty for something
you didn't do
politicians take your money
then they uh then they throw these
stimulus
things out there but then they're gonna
take your money again when
during tax season they're going to tax
that stimulus that they just gave you so
they're going to get more money
and then they're going to give
themselves raises to get more money
right and i mentioned this year i just
for those of you who
have already filed your taxes you
already know i filed mine
last month lo and behold the question
came up
did you get the first stimulus and it
showed me the amount so they knew
how much i was supposed to say yes to
and they said did you get the second one
because this is how much it should have
been
i just say yes do it do it properly
and then the tax credits that you
normally get every year in and year out
you don't get now
so so so was it a stimulus or was it
what the hell was it it's never been a
simulator
they are the biggest criminals boy it
was for gender studies in pakistan
it was for gender studies in pakistan i
wonder how much they had to pay back
and i i know our candidate uh phenomenal
candidate definitely if you live out
there in south central support him
there's no question about that but he
mentioned
san francisco i was reading an article
this morning
that the san francisco life
is below like anything in the nation
the the the cost of living is through
the roof
people are unhappy to live there they
don't want to be there i mean it's just
a really
this democrat ideologies and policies
that
whether underground movement i brought
it up at the beginning of the show
you brought them up they're in office
out there as
the d.a in san fran freako letting
people
out on the streets and no bail and all
that crazy nonsense
the weather on the ground you said the
weather on the ground is in california
well they spread out throughout the
nation but bill clinton pardoned
uh ayers and dorne and all the all the
others pardon them all
but now they're in office they're
holding academia their
district attorney out san fran freco i
mean
they're in politics president trump
sent a cease and desist letter to three
gop
groups demanding that they stop raising
money
off of his name if that's one thing that
president trump is proud of
that's his name even though that they
didn't have the democrats and the rhinos
have tried
to destroy his name that's one thing he
is proud of is his name
however the republican party has defied
trump or at least
that's what they're that's what it's
looking like and they said that they
will continue using his name in
fundraising appeals
because he approves of it or he has
approved of it
what do y'all think it's a time in a
place where it's got to stop
donald trump built up his brand and the
trump
name worldwide with the likes that
i i don't know maybe kiss might be in
second place behind him
but but the trump brand worldwide
is huge he did that his team did that
in a lifetime of work to make that
happen and for the republican party now
after all said and done now to continue
to steal off that because they're losers
and they got no new ideas
i'm just shocked actually by it because
the republican party doesn't fight for
their people
they didn't fight for trump and all of a
sudden they fight on this
they haven't fought on anything in the
past eight four years for him
or ever and now they're fighting him on
this this is the one thing they chose
to fight on and go again
they lay down and roll over on
everything else yes
we got um we have another guest that is
joining the show
uh he is the uh um
uh a podcaster uh uh a radio voice out
there
um he has a show dad talk
today uh his name is
eric carroll what's up eric how are you
doing
hey what's going on wayne um
dead talk today dad talk today
so i guess you talk about dads and stuff
yeah man the fatherless issue it's an
epidemic going on right now and
i wanted dad talk and it had a lot of
money because it's a very
commonly searched theme so got the today
we got it for half price
did you have a booth at cpac we did yes
sir
i saw you there i was like what had a
crowd of people and everybody standing
around watching you man
so great job hey i appreciate appreciate
that you know we talk about an issue
that's
not commonly talked about and it was an
issue that people were glad to talk
about
many of our legislators and our
candidates that are running have been
through these issues so they was really
excited about it now
we love cpac man so why did you start
the podcast what did it give me the
background and all that
all right so i was a single father that
went through divorce and was raising my
two daughters uh on my own
and i jumped straight back into a
relationship and i got with someone that
it was a nightmare guys and uh once i
started trying to get custody in my
child
i start going to these family lawyers
and i see the racket that's going on
i paid four hundred dollars to consult
with one for an hour and he told me it
was cheaper to keep her i needed to get
back with her
that's not happened before i've heard
that
oh man you gotta run from the succubus
wow it's a swamp and then i go to
another lawyer
he tells me you got one the best cases
i've heard of but i need ten thousand
dollars on retainer and it's like i
don't have ten thousand i'm a single
father i started realizing it's like our
kids are a product
out of divorce they know you'll pay to
see your kids and they made a big
business out of it
yeah these these uh these policies
that are being pushed by daddy
government is
not the best thing for america's family
and one thing
one thing that uh we need to realize as
americans and i'm sure that
you can expand on this is that the fam
i the reason why america is suffering so
much
is not from the top down it's from the
bottom
up a lot of families are split and when
the family is split
that that leaks into the community well
it
at least into the neighborhood the
neighborhood leads them to the community
the community leads into the city city
into
the the region the state and then the
state
goes nationwide then you have a broken
america
am i right oh absolutely man the
breakdown in the nuclear family if you
get parents out of the household
that can actually teach their kids
morals you can control a nation and i'm
afraid for the next generation that's
coming up a lot of them are growing up
without their parents and uh
i guess you see man it's lost we've had
what peter pan dr seuss saw this in the
past
week in the direction that our nation is
going in i'm
very scared of the future for our kids
yeah potato head
yeah we talk about this on the show
quite often but
um when we talk about the morals when we
talk about the nuclear family
um i i i bring this up because it was
part of me growing up and me you as well
uh we we were forced to go to church we
hated church and it was
it was a pain and now it's so painful
and boring
and whatnot but but after we uh
ran reckless and straight into a bridge
abutment in our 20s we realized oh wow
man i i need to get back to church and
get myself straight
this this generation doesn't have that
no and it's it's kind of interesting you
say that i was a pastor son
both of my granddads pastors so i grew
up in that so i
really i really you know kind of had a
little chip on my shoulder when it came
to church because i had to go to the
revivals and everything as soon as i
would come home from school
but as i got older i started realizing
those morals that my parents had
instilled in me
and they came back around all those
values that i once took for granted
and that's again that's what i'm afraid
that this generation is not going to
have
you know now you use
in one of your interviews i heard you
say something about a parental what did
you call it where one parent gaslights
the other what's that called
[Music]
parental alienation is where one parent
brainwashes the child to not want a
relationship with the other parent
and when i first started this i thought
that it was
rare this is a very common thing and
just like false allegations false
allegations are at an all-time high
we're seeing them in our politics and
we're seeing them in the families if
somebody makes a
false accusation of molestation or
domestic violence it just completely
cripples that other parent
and to prove their innocence is very
very hard and these attorneys are almost
pushing people to do that to get the
upper hand and we we've got to stop that
well i've seen that firsthand myself i
said come from a twice broken home
adopted and then the family i was
adopted into went through a wretched
divorce
and i saw that firsthand and i saw where
the each parent
whoever we were with that parent we
would side with that parent
and then we'd go back to the other one
and we would talk crap about that one to
that
because of the positive reinforcement
that we
got when we were with mom she wanted all
the juice on
on dad and so we got that positive
reinforcement then we were with him
and then he would give us that
reinforcement a positive uh
we're talking about her in in the
the the breakdown of the child the
destruction and the abuse the mental
abuse
of these children uh how do we
where do we start well you got some
solutions it's not a
one you know size fits all solution but
marriage we're at a 55
divorce rate in america right now over
half of our marriages are ending in a
divorce
you're taking two people that once upon
a time they loved each other
now you're putting them in court fussing
over the dog the house all this
if we had some legislation that said mom
and dad are created equal
okay and they get equal custody upon
divorce and it promotes co-parenting
working together even though you're not
together
you still got a relationship for your
children and doing what's in their best
interest
if we had some legislation like that i
believe a lot of this would start to
heal itself
what what do uh what do a lot of your
listeners
uh talk to you about or
what are some of their main issues uh
that they come to you with well one
what they're having to spend inside a
family court to be with their children i
had a guy a month ago
he had been listening to my show from
the very beginning and uh he had reached
out to me at thanksgiving he had
what they called a silver bullet a false
allegation molestation
or domestic violence he had proved that
he didn't do it they had footage to show
that he had never done
any of this he was completely exonerated
and a
couple of weeks ago when he went to pick
up his kids
the father-in-law got out of the car and
shot and murdered him
i mean and then just yesterday guys we
had another father up in pennsylvania
uh when he got to the custody exchange
to pick up his kids
mom's boyfriend killed him and his
girlfriend
and then we had that father right after
that i got the news in new york
the mom's boyfriend beat his 10 year old
son to death
this is uh there's a common thread with
these women
they got to stop they got to stop doing
to these men and these men get triggered
and they want to fix it
yeah do you think that that's why judges
side
on the women's side more than the men
because it's more likely the men that
are doing the shooting and the killing
of the women
well i i gotta be honest with you there
is a law and you'll have to read up on
it but it's called title ivd
title 4d of the social security act the
states actually make
incentives from the federal government
off of every dollar that's paid in child
support
so it's in their best interest to make
sure this guy is paying two or three
thousand dollars a month
because the state's getting more
kickbacks from that it's been
incentivized and nobody should be making
incentives off the destruction of broken
families
and that's you know the the mainstream
most people in modern society
they don't know about this this is
really important stuff i mean
that's what's breaking down our country
we've got to get the number one solution
to everything we're seeing going on
right now is making sure those parents
are in their home with their kids
and you know these judges are making
money making sure that that doesn't
happen in attorneys and
it's a swamp it really is a swamp so say
that again you said that
the that the the judges or the state or
who's getting extra kickbacks off of uh
these um these child support payments or
whatnot
the state is making incentives the
federal government reimburses them
especially when it comes like welfare
and different things like that and it's
hidden under the social security act but
there's many other ways they're making
money
like if you're a father that's paying
child support or mothers this happens to
them as well it's a 85 percent
dad issue but they're getting their
butts handed to them too
uh every time you pay child support they
they charge you like a 3.50
processing fee now that might not seem
like much but when you've got 25 million
parents in the united states that are
paying child support and every month you
get that 3.50
processing fee guys it's a business you
know now that you say that i know
an individual a mom that was finally
able to claim
the the ex-husband on her taxes and he
hasn't
paid anything whatsoever okay so she
claimed him for the corona check and all
that stuff so she could at least get
something for the children yeah all of
that
went through the feds first and it
funneled out and then
wound up coming back to her didn't go
from the irs to her bank account
it went through the government and it
got their sticky fingers on the money
that she
so desperately needed right well i heard
you talking about the stimulus checks
before i came on here i mean there's
ways
if you are uh a father or a mother that
was in arrears they took your stimulus
check from you and then
there was incentives made off of that
they made their money back
in many different ways and we're talking
about where some people were without
jobs
you know some of these people aren't
deadbeats they're dead broke
and it's hard you know i think there's
got to be
some type of maximum i believe kids do
need support but they need their parents
more than anything
and if we make sure that both are doing
their jobs child support wouldn't be
as big of an issue as people make it out
to be
so what what is your best advice for a
dad or mom that's going through this
right in the heat of it they haven't
seen their child in almost a year what
is like the number one piece that
helped you through what you were through
personally what what could you give them
finding other parents that are going
through the same thing and talking about
it when you're going through this you
feel like you're the only one
and it's it kind of makes you feel like
you're a loner there are so many people
that are going through these issues guys
and if you find yourself getting in that
highly contentious divorce
make sure you document everything
because when you go to court you can say
she did this she did that she did that
you've got to be able to prove it
okay and these people are really good at
what they do when we talk about
alienators and parental alienation a lot
of times narcissism and mental health
issues are tied along to it
they are good at what they do so you got
to make sure that you're on your toes
ready to respond for when it comes your
way
you know what i like i like that you
have taken the fight
to the issue um that you haven't sat
on the side because there are a lot of
people
that are going through or they have gone
through what you have gone through
and they probably have great stories but
they're so broken and hurt that
they but um
they're in that state of oppression that
they can't get out
to make a difference and uh um
get healing through helping other people
and i i can see through
what you're doing that you are helping a
lot of people
um where can people reach out to get you
well real quick i'd like to give a
statistic on that wayne
suicide in men in their 20s and 30s is
seven times higher than that of women
and most of that's tied into the family
law issue
wow where um where do you
see what do you want your
your voice to go
in the future with dead talk today what
do you want people
to know about what you're doing and how
can they help you
i'm a little bit different than most
shows dad talk is the show i want to end
i want to find solutions let's get them
in place so i can go and do shows like
what you're doing right there you know
that's what i inspired to do but until
these laws are changed
um it's a fight that we're in and i just
want to see everybody come together
because it's going to take
us getting the awareness out there um to
make this happen and finding out things
about like title 4d that's never been
said on a big platform
and i believe if people knew that the
states was making incentives
they wouldn't go for that so yeah i
didn't even know about that
for some i've ever heard any of this
yeah and
um to hear that that's that's
that's uh that's very that's frustrating
yes sir anybody man okay so we got um
dad talk today at gmail.com
www.dead.
any last any last thoughts you want to
leave for the audience
hey guys we need everybody involved
we're probably the biggest on facebook
we've grew to around a quarter of a
million and that's just in a year's time
i will say since we've got back to cpac
i've seen my numbers
it seems like if you're posting
conservative content
they just completely censor the crap out
of you and that's frustrating because we
put so much work in
to making this content but anybody that
can show up and support
we need it we're up against a 55 billion
a year industry
and we're having a hard time getting
donations but we're going across the
country talking to our legislators
and we want to find the candidates that
support us because they're the ones
we're going to support in return all
right
that said my man thank you so much eric
um
what what day do you broadcast and what
time do you brought in
it's it's kind of weird because i know i
need a set time to like tomorrow i'm
going up to michigan we're going to the
state capitol to meet with legislators
the week after that i'm going to iowa
so i've got 50 different interviews that
we did
jim jordan mike lindell and a lot of
those guys at cpac that i haven't even
got to post yet
um because they got to be edited down so
we
usually try to do it on around monday or
tuesday later on tonight the family of
the guy that got murdered i was telling
you about in idaho john mast
his family will be coming on to tell
some of the details on that so
just just try to watch the schedule i
try to post a day before
we do an interview and uh join us live
we
we need you thank you man thank you hey
guys thank you
thanks yeah i'm on his facebook page
right now and there's a store there's a
store there guys
you buy stuff help support the guy
absolutely what a phenomenal cause
it's crazy what he said about cpac
because i watched our numbers
actually go high prior to cpac as soon
as you went live cpac
then i started to watch our numbers go
and i thought here we go again with
facebook they're suppressing again
i mean that's sickening well they knew
the time they knew when cpac was on
yeah you know they got our ip they
actually had
probably access to everybody's ip
address because the hotel
set up and oddly enough
all the internet for everybody went down
at one time shuttered by showdown
yes sure did that everybody's show was
completely shut down
at um 3 30 3 30 on
wednesday on thursday i think
yeah our first day arkansas passed his
first statewide ban on all
abortions except for in medical
emergencies
that's definitely going to the supreme
court
um
hmm that's headed in the right direction
though hold on hold on now
yeah in a way
uh oh yeah come on man spit it what what
what y'all think about that the girl had
leah
[Laughter]
there's three different excerpts in
there which one
that they passed it or that that it's
not
just for abortions that medical
emergencies are the exception like what
are we
what are you asking my opinion on what
you think about them passing
the ban on all abortions
except for american emergencies i'm not
surprised i mean this is what they've
been trying to
get done this is what the democrats have
been fighting him on democrats say kill
kill kill
just kill them doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if they're newborn coming right
out or if they're
three months in there kill them arkansas
says no we don't want to do that
right and when we talk about medical
emergencies if you do any kind of
research whatsoever you will find these
doctors say
in a medical emergency the quickest
fastest safest for the woman maybe she's
going through a heart attack maybe
a high blood pressure medical whatever
we're going to lose the mom
or we're going to lose the baby the
fastest most safest way to do it
deliver the baby deliver a healthy baby
so so literally
it is going to be extremely rare from
what i've seen doctors say
to have uh legitimacy for an abortion
which is phenomenal because people 100
years from now
are going to look back as we look back
on slavery now people are going to look
back
on our society now and say oh my god
what
remember though medical emergency
doesn't mean when you're just in labor
and the only reason why i'm saying that
to you is i had preeclampsia with my
daughter
and they told me do not ever ever ever
get pregnant again because you will die
you will be very close to death
my blood pressure was like 200 over 190.
um and my doctor had said to me if in
fact you would become pregnant again and
you get into a medical emergency four
months into your pregnancy
like you did this one you would be
eligible for an abortion
so they're also talking about that type
of medical emergency too where you could
not deliver the baby
you're five months pregnant but your
blood pressure is 200 over 190 and
you're ready to stroke
out on the table my sister-in-law
uh gave birth at five months and the
girl is
a beautiful six-year-old three months
four months because my preeclampsia
started so what do you do then
that's what i'm just asking i'm not
disagreeing with you i'm a disagreeing
with the issue
because i'm just questioning that what
would a woman do you're only three and a
half months pregnant your blood
pressure's 200 over 190
and they're saying you're probably gonna
stroke out and die what are you gonna do
for the next night is six months
and the baby you can't deliver it it
doesn't even have lungs yet i
can't even imagine how rare that
situation is though
i am but it happens even one time
i am and most of you know i'm i'm
pro-life
i'm pro-life my uh
my i was adopted my uh birth mother
uh couldn't make up and could make
remind whether to have me
or to get rid of me and uh
then the state came in when
i was born and then she didn't know
whether to keep me
or to get rid of me so the state came in
and put me in social services is that
what i thought
right okay so with that said
i am pro-life or i wouldn't be here
um and if you
do this ban of all abortions
i understand and i say
okay because i am against the bush
but a whole i but pandora's box is
getting ready to open if that's the case
a pandora's box is getting reopened for
a whole lot of issues
such as climate change
oh okay i see where you're going i
thought you meant
in in general with abortions i'm saying
you're saying it will branch out into
other issues
oh yeah because i'm not making the
connection
oh um if they ban if they ban the murder
of babies
that's a good thing across the board and
then we'll have
well hold on it's a good thing for those
who believe in it yes
you're right it's a bad well when you
show the woman
the heartbeat and you show the woman
the baby it doesn't matter it's a human
being
so you're saying wayne if they ban all
gas cars
for people that don't like gas cars
that's a good thing but for the other
people it might be an issue
they could do that
well if they ban real meat and everybody
has to eat
eat genetically modified meats like you
know they want all vegetarian meat
so you're saying if they can ban
abortions then technically the left
should be able to have their beliefs too
that
red meat is not good for you in turn you
must eat this 3d printed meat
because you're saving lives or or yeah
i mean they can't that's pandora's box
they can do
i mean pandora pandora's box can't and
and actually with this bill this um hr
one
pandora's there is no more top to
pandora's box
you're not gonna you are not gonna put
the top back on the box
after this thing is signed it's done
it's over
we let you ban abortions now we need to
ban red meat
we got to do something okay well i
disagree with that
premise completely and i know democrats
probably go after it
but i disagree with that on the basis
that
life is life
hold on your blind is just stuck on life
i'm talking about everything else
is life so therefore you have to ban me
well it's an animal animals are
completely animals don't have a soul i
don't have a soul well how's it
as much as people love their cats and
their dogs i understand you make this
psychological connection
right and i'm not going to inherit liam
i'm not what did you say
they're called what babies yeah animals
i'm just saying you know the democrats
that's exactly what they're gonna go for
their cutthroat
if you ban abortions because you feel
like life is life they're going to come
back and say well
cows are life pigs are like they breathe
air they bond with their parents
they drink the milk their parents just
like humans do
you need to 3d print me they're animals
and they don't have
i know but they're animals and they
don't have
humans hold on okay but you know what
aoc is going to say
she's not going to you can tell her that
and she's going to say but they breathe
life
and they they have emotions you know it
i understand and many people yes it is
murder when you abort a baby
all i'm saying is and and
and i i mean if the people of arkansas
agree with this
that's fine that's their state i'm
pro-life i'm against i'm
i will always be against abortion that's
me
that's what i believe i'm just saying
that the same thing i said when
president trump did the national
emergency for the border wall
when the democrats get in office they're
going to use that national emergency on
some bull crap stuff
and there's nothing that we yeah i know
we're going to complain about it
yeah yeah we're going to fuss and tweet
about it
but we don't have any candle to hold to
it because
president trump used national emergency
which was in hit
which was in the interest of america
to build the border wall with emergency
funds
they can come out right now and use
emergency funds for obamacare
they can use emergency funds for
electric cars
they can use emergency funds for the
second amendment if they wanted to
they can lie and create something so and
they do
right and they do yeah next week they're
coming up with
now i i know i know me and brian go back
and forth on the second amendment thing
next week they're supposed to be voting
on the second amendment thing i know
in congress if they make it a national
emergency
if biden strokes it on a pin what not
there's nothing i mean you can't
complain
well actually you can't complain but
you're complaining at a wall
because you know but then with the last
administration but
see we we've got we've got amendments
that that
in our constitution that are inherently
given to us by our creator freedom
assembly freedom church freedom no
worship
freedom to defend myself
amendments was given to us by our
forefathers not creators
right inalienable rights given to us by
god
well our founders our founders our
forefathers wrote on paper
was given to us by god the unalienable
rights was already in the constitution
right
these basic rights that we these truths
that we hold dear
given to us by god right but the
but the unalienable rights was created
in the initial constitution based on
what my name wrote the amendments
are to change things of course i mean
and and
you can say they were spiritually you
know intervention amendments are the
rules for the government what the
government can't do
and they don't like that you know as
changes to what was done before
that might not have covered everything
or they want to make changes to it
because they didn't like what was done
before that's what amendments are
right no yeah
yeah like the first i mean
maybe i'm maybe i'm crossing wires here
i don't understand where you come from
okay um
when something isn't i mean
again amendments are
to make something clear or to change
something that they don't like
okay okay for instance
we had slaves we made an amendment 14th
amendment 15 minutes
mass space proclamation
those things weren't in the constitution
first amendment
right to speech we want that known
second amendment right
to defend yourself want that known okay
you you start adding things that's why
people go around saying well well if you
don't like this
uh create an amendment to the
constitution
okay that's tough to do yeah but i mean
that's really true
right it's tough to do but that's
usually what people say
if you don't agree with someone in the
constitution write an amendment for it
and then pass it through kanye it's
tough to do
that's why a whole lot of people don't
do it
and then or the executive orders come
out of nowhere
you know people might not even know
around an amendment
right well and people might not even
know but the um
um the ban on alcohol that's still in
our
it's still there they just put it made
an amendment
to that which is still there 21st
amendment
they made the amendment to amend um what
am i looking for
ban on alcohol what was uh
ban on alcohol so it's still there the
ban is still there
in the on on the books
they made an amendment to say that that
doesn't count anymore
yeah yeah so there's your little
amendment
lesson for the day he's not easy i don't
think you're gonna
you can't amend you can't amend the
second amendment
to say if they tried in 2010 they tried
to say
here's our amendment to the second
amendment a right to you have to be in a
militia
and they redefine militia as a military
organization
they tried to amend it but it didn't
happen and so that's where
i get frustrated with these politicians
who are coming after the second
amendment
to amend it to mean something it never
intended to mean
right you can amend an amendment yes
that's okay so i think i think if you
circle back
to everything else then
you know we're on the same page right i
was literally going to just say
schoolhouse rock but quinton beat me to
it
oh no well that's awesome i think that
is badge of honor
and yeah become a bill on the hill
i want to thank everybody for tuning in
to the show today
tomorrow's thursday we got some more
guests coming up
we got some more gifts i got some old
gas for you
um let us know how we can support you
guys other than joining
patreon and sharing the show you can't
let's see
you can go to our sponsors
you could do that you could go to our
mail
if you're currently using cbd for any
reason
here's now a chance an opportunity to
try a product that we
support we believe in it works
i've tried it i've used it my sister
tried it i censored you my mom tried it
my mommy
it for them i mean i got three in a row
right now so if you're currently using
cbd
yeah right if you're currently using cbd
jump over
to cbdlion.com backslash wayne dupree
and get uh
20 off save up 20
and then to really pamper yourself get
your cbd gummy take one of those and
then
get yourself a my pillow or maybe a my
pillow weighted blanket
or the my pillow towels which soak up
all the water
the my pillow sheets wait till you fill
those sheets on your body
you will you cannot imagine right and
the topper comes with two free pillows
there you go so all you have to do is go
to mypillow.com
and uh radio specials and code word
wayne
wayne is the key word to all three
will set you free to relaxation and
comfort
and hold and go and knowing that your
your your 401k is secure knowing that
your money is taken care of backed by
gold
no other way to do it um
let me see i
all three of these are our sponsors
and we believe in them totally we
believe in them totally or we wouldn't
even
push it out to you like like we said
i'm trying to i'm trying to get some
gold for my kids
because i because i don't believe in the
government to do anything good
for my kids all right okay
the my pillow that's for me the my
pillow works for my head
and my back the uh how do you call it
the
the mattress topper works for my back
um and for a nice comfort feel
the cbd line and i really
hope that you all try this i i really do
i really hope that y'all try this
the cbd line is
for pain anxiety
stress it works ladies and gentlemen
it is this wait hold on wait a minute
i gotta i gotta get this look at my eyes
i'm serious as a heart attack if two
strokes follow this
that cbd works uh
i mean the way that all three of us
connected
and talk to each other when we got it
and how we used and whatnot
it made believers out of all of us
something i wanted to mention about the
vape pens
they have the cbd vape pens if you're
trying to quit smoking
it's just this comes from a smoker who
gets nervous and gets anxious moved to
the vape pens
nervous and anxious hit the vape try the
cbd vape pen
get off the nicotine get away from all
that garbage nancy in the chat says i've
ordered from my pillow and cbd line and
now i'm sleeping like a baby
hey i love you nancy hey yay
i love you thank you theresa says listen
to him folks it works the products are
high quality
and she's talking about absolutely
we're not just telling you this there
you go teresa teresa says listen to him
folks
the gummies smell amazing it just
they're so delicious i always have to
show them off because they're so pretty
look how pretty
they are eat two of them
take a break thank you nancy
um and and today
today wouldn't be a day without
putting somebody on oblivion island
someone's going to the island but
um quentin says michael lindell is
setting up a new site is that right
i haven't heard uh
clinton's usually on top of it um you
know
we have to look into that i would assume
he is considering he's running for
some type of office he would have to
start somewhere
and tim tim says fleet farm still
sells my pillow yeah now everywhere when
i go shopping
i automatically notice if they're still
selling my pillow
or not so yeah support
uh new york post uh 23 hours ago
said that mike lindell claims he's
launching his own social media site
that was uh new york post good plan
so we'll stay on top of that why not
really
that'd be to join it as soon as it
launches live
um give him a call see what he's doing
i am on so many it's crazy it's it's
almost
insanity like i'm not going to do that
there's just too many i mean i
understand you have to
i mean i try to keep up it's impossible
well yeah yeah i'm all day on it
just sign up and then i forget about it
and when i go back i use the same
uh name you know my name brian smith for
all of them
and one of the ones that you mentioned
here recently i went back i said
there's already a user on that oh right
i made one up back in the day and i
forgot about it yeah
so how about joe at the hardwood
hardware store
not taking questions shoot away so that
way nobody could ask him questions
yesterday boy did he look lost
i mean yeah i'll be honest with you i've
seen
alzheimer's patients in stores like
because my mother used to take care of
alzheimer's patients
and she would come in her name was
mildred and she would enjoy herself she
would go grocery shopping with us
she looked less loss lost than what he
did yesterday
that's alarming
oh my lord jesus you are so great
in all of your magnificent splendor
um all right man
i know i know i did i just gave that
just came to me
uh we are getting ready to go
last thoughts yo last thoughts that was
my last thought
um yeah we got a lot going on here when
it comes to politics it comes
as i mentioned earlier before the
weather underground movement there's a
lot of these historical events that we
have uh
forgotten and the media wants us to
forget look at the new shiny thing over
here look at this look at
that look at this look at that slow down
every once in a while
dial it back and uh start talking to
your kids about some of the historical
things that have happened in the past
about where the clintons come from
about what the government the biden
biden
his history it's all over the tick tocks
now but still
keep on playing quentin keep on playing
oh sweden
wayne is a biscuit clinton dance is on
the edge there don't it
you about playing
[Laughter]
i'm stamping tickets to oblivion island
just a quick
and brian looks like shaggy from scooby
what
now shy you look homeless he was
homeless chic
i don't know he only was more like he
only had this he had this little patch
i know i've been watching the scooby-doo
with the kids for the past three days
they love me
quentin is at least letting us know one
thing
quentin has not moved to rumble
oh uh oh why are you procrastinating
better not be a procrastinator quentin
uh oh
recall newsome knew some uh yeah newsome
real quick
is what kind of 50 000
signatures signatures for his recall
yeah i just hope you all got somebody in
the waiting
that's not republican don't don't throw
up right don't throw up arnold
schwarzenegger likes
oh don't regurgitate that he gave a
statement
he gave a state of state address
i don't i've never had one one of you
two said that you'd mail me one never
did
i only have this wayne why didn't you
mail it to her i only have this
wayne why didn't you mail it to her he
said he was gonna mail it to her
did i yeah you did well
wait what will i send you a black one
yes please
because i only have i only have one i
only have one white one you look like
you got a bullet head with that too
oh yeah this thing look at that
look at this look at this put on your
other glasses with that hat
other glasses yeah we're gonna crack up
oh this is going to be
these no the other one
oh yeah those ones yeah
what are we doing here
[Music]
okay